bonsoir alors le disait téléspectateurs
deux de marit la première alors vous
venez rares mesures inégales comme hier
je le disais une filmographie
impressionnante une vie débordante
d'activités qui donne presque le tournis
vous n'avez jamais eu envie de vous
arrêter un petit peu juste de faire une
pause donc ces dépositions que je donne
mais finalement cela qu avec vous et je
n'ai pas tout cela les contrôleurs du
cycle à ce festival et film oui mais il
ya des choses qu'on doit compte paypal
refusé de faire paul douat part à la vie
de la cité ça a été moins important
juste pour que nous soyons visibles
si vous croisez fait deux mandatures et
jetés en ville de la la le dix neuvième
voilà mais sinon oui mais si j'avais eu
à travailler
vous avez participé à l'écriture de
l'ouvragé noires n'est pas mon métier
très connu dans lequel vous avez dénoncé
les rôles c'est exterio type est dévolue
aux actrices noir en plus de vingt ans
de carrière
est-ce que vous avez vu le cinéma évolue
et justement dans ce secteur alors c'est
vrai que cette année ça fait 30 ans loin
vêtements pour eux et ça y est les
autres noms des jo nous étions 16 à
vouloir en parler c'était ce livre a été
écrit à l'initiative de deuil c'est
maigre et qui est une médecine bucco
américaine aussi dois mais vous
finalement il fallait qu'on dénonce
quand elle m'a appelé tout de suite j'ai
dit oui parce que j'avais des choses que
je pouvais dire parce que c'est vrai il
ya une palette de comédiens et ça va de
la 25e à moi et donc à des choses que je
pouvais dire que les autres ne pouvaient
pas si vous l'avez vécu en plus un
écueil et voilà par rapport aux autres
jeunes filles aujourd'hui d'abord l'a
fait ce livre vous dénoncez un peu
ferrand concerts et j'avoue que jours
difficiles d'anouar est passé à la
télévision française et les choses
avancent un peu quand même ça a eu quand
même des percussions et à des jeunes
filles à ses dirigeants qui ont changé
au niveau du social je veux dire et puis
voix il faut absolument être sur le
terrain c'est un combat de longue
haleine le faut dire les choses comme il
faut qu'on pouvait le trouver là le bon
moment posé les choses
firmine richard vous êtes de passage en
martinique parce que vous êtes fait
partie du casting du nouveau film de
julien dalle secrets de famille qui sera
projeté en avant première demain soir un
film tourné intégralement en angleterre
avec des acteurs et des techniciens
antillais je vous propose cet extrait
avec delphine baisse et stéphane petit
frère pôle financier à la city semblent
avoir tout réussi dans sa vie quand elle
est tellement il ya un ressort qui s'est
cassé chez toi tu as commencé à couper
les ponts avec tout le monde avec ta
famille et ma pompe
tu es plus le même mais un lourd secret
le poussin jours à détruire tout ce
qu'ils en trouvent
or quelle somme est indescriptible
créée
le cinéma antillais saint cinéma qui à
40 ans il ya déjà deux magnifiques films
qui ont été faits par tous les
réalisateurs qu'on connaît nous a
beaucoup vu dans des comédies
et je trouvais qu'il était intéressant
cette fois de s'attaquer au drame après
mes deux précédents films qui était
plutôt de l'ordre de la comédie
quand j'étais au collège on a été voir
le film
il ya déjà quelques années
6 millions d'euzhan palcy et c'était la
première fois que je voyais des acteurs
entier à l'écran et pour moi ça a été un
véritable choc
et du coup je pense que c'est très
important de pouvoir que le public
vienne voir ces films là nos films parce
que du coup on peut voir un petit peu d
histoire qui nous ressemble à place
média et non d'un cocktail you know my
job
comment faire annulation money money
back baby will be blood chrome ayé ayé
tout est allé trop loin tu es allé trop
loin quand le film est sorti en
guadeloupe on avait évidemment beaucoup
d'appréhension parce que le film est une
petite production avec un budget très
très très modeste et il y avait beaucoup
d pour d'appréhension pour savoir si le
public appréciera le fil
et puis effectivement il ya là il ya la
même appréhension ici en arctique et on
espère sincèrement qu'un maximum de gens
viendront voir le film thriller
dramatique secret de famille at-on son
public à partir de demain à madiana
le problème c'est
si ce papa
[Musique]
voilà donc un film un film qui est à
voir donc demain sur les écrans donc de
madiana
et vendredi la première firmine richard
un film à petit budget comme a dit le
réalisateur mon nom ça vous a plu qu'est
ce qui vous a plu dans l'algérois
effectivement il soit ma plus j'avais
fait son possible un film et donc non
l'histoire m'a intéressé et puis c'est
vrai que je dis que tu te film sans
prétention avec la contre une belle
histoire qui la côte
un drame des dames familiale c'était un
rôle où elle m'a pas encore vu donc tout
de suite
j'étais intéressé puis ça s'est passé en
angleterre c'est l'occasion de parler en
anglais de tous dans l'onglet parler
d'un synode étrangères et puis notez ça
m'a plu tout de suite vous jouez encore
le rôle d'une mère une mère de famille
c'est aller vers des drogues musique est
vraiment attachés et à ce rôle elle vos
abonnés romuald et juliette
après ma première étoile on vous connaît
uniquement dans ces rôles de mère de
famille est tellement naturelle on a
l'impression que vous jouez même plus
vous êtes vous même mais je crois que
c'est son rôle de mère ce petit talibans
vous garder mais je ne peux pas ceci mon
axe dans le monde du cinéma car il y
avait 40 ans donc je crois que nos
premiers films on n'a pas demandé de
changer mon accent heureusement dieu
affaire à une une
réalisatrice qui connaît le mot noir
déjà aussi qui m'a plu tel que je suis
d'ailleurs j'ai été l'objet d'une
conversation je dis mais pourquoi moi et
me dit que j'avais une actuellement ce
qui ne s'apprend pas je l'avais je vais
apprendre ce qu'ils font est joué on
vous en parle aujourd'hui de cet accent
mais j'ai ce que ça m'a saoulé c'est un
atout oui je l'aï toujours dit mon accès
fait la différence
donc on a besoin d'eux va de 2 d'avoir
un accent de titi parisien et à des
fables des jeunes femmes de chez nous
qui sommes nés en france ou qui vivent
leur nouvel axe faire ça vous savez
c'est donc on devrait passer parce qu'on
sait on veut point avec puisque j'ai mes
kilos aux homos l'accent est tout de
même
donc c'est comme ça qu'on vous aime
firmine richard alors un film à petit
budget à côté des grosses productions
gros investissements il y à ses fils qui
heureusement existe malgré tout trouver
des fonds c'est jamais évident encore
moins quand on vit dans la caraïbe les
choses bougent un peu vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure aussi mais pas assez
selon vous qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour faire bouger les choses dans le
cinéma
non je dis au niveau de la visibilité
des choses ont commencé à changer mais
financièrement par là c'est toujours
très difficile de tva films et il n'y a
pas que nous mais un gros pire pour le
jeune réalisateur il sait d'où cela que
dès que l'occasion se présente de donner
un coup de main et elle était il faut le
faire ils ont besoin d'une relève donc
si je les électeurs il faut des idées
je sais que il ya des situations qui
font la démarche mais sait pas s'il ne
se fait pas avec une institution il faut
aller trouver les fonds là où ils se
trouvent et ce n'est pas toujours
évident d'être connu sur ce héros qui
sauve qui se monte un acquis que qui
ferment aussi à l'origine chaque année
donc c'est pas une histoire simple mais
de toute façon il faut pas des êtres les
encourager il faut vouloir et aider ceux
qui en veulent qui veulent faire du
cinéma parce que je dis que c'est à nous
de raconter nos histoires de jeunes le
font très bien donc il faut les idées
que tu fous merci